[Music]  this is the decision that's been a long  time coming people have actually been  asking me to do this for nine years I  think where some of those people have  asked you in many interviews and I'm  sure friends as well who has been sort  of one of your biggest supporters you  know it's really people nine years who  were start who were asking me were  really other public school parents that  I was fighting alongside for better  schools and I would say really the  public school community and some of my  amazing iris I got to ask know that sex  in city 3 is shelved was that the final  push not at all No  thank you so much see what the rally  [Music]  [Applause]